[Music]
being out here in the middle of the
everglades in the dark
this is all new and
out of my element and
that's the kind of stuff i
like oh there he is there he is
he's right underneath this mangrove i
mean
coming in
look
[Music]
there you out good job my first uh solo
capture and he's gonna poop on me
i'm not gonna pretend like i know what
i'm doing because guess what i don't
i don't know
don't
stay with him you got it i know a lot
about predators
i've studied bears my whole life i've
followed wolves year-round and i've
tracked mountain lions from the rockies
to the desert
there's one top american predator i'm
missing
so i'm heading to gator
nice one casey i let this guy go i'm
bringing my skills to the swamp to learn
how this place works big dude
how it's changing
and what makes gators america's coolest
predator in that line
yeah look at the size of that thing this
is america
the wild
you tell me where you want it
man they're so strong it's like when he
does that shake it
takes everything to hang out in this
pool
tomorrow i'm headed into the swamps
today is my dress rehearsal for the wild
okay
your job is to keep tension through this
pole okay
jen bruggen is a biologist at saint
augustine alligator all right hold up
speed up she's capturing some gators for
a physical exam
i'm going to jump on that croc and i'm
going to need all that tension and all
that power pointed in this direction so
he doesn't turn around on me invite me
gotcha you ready got it
all right hey are you ready ready where
you are
all right so i'm picking up this tail
this has to be all in one motion okay
here i go
nice quick when it comes to america's
wildest predators there's about a
thousand grizzly bears and three
thousand wolves in the lower 48 states
but there's over 5 million gators
and i've never seen one in the wild
that's got to change
all right so you're going to try and
snare this big one looking right at us
now don't be afraid if i start yelling
at you don't take it personally i'm
trying to save your life
all right dude okay so nice and easy
now he's wise to this i would think so
there you go
and general if you need to come this way
keep going keep going
i love you pass the jowls
[Applause]
digging in alrighty
guy is strong
you can tell he's not happy i'll tell
you what i don't know how long i can sit
here and hold him like this guy's strong
he's trying to get away there you go
keeping tension okay go starting to pull
okay why is that guys heavy
everybody one two three pull
watch one two three pull
all right keeping tension we want to get
him secure before we put him on the
board okay
oh hang on holy
everyone keep tension on that rope
it's amazing that that tape actually
will hold that joshua look at the size
of that thing if this guy really wanted
to probably take us all right into the
pond
huffing and puffing if a bear's doing
that it means the same thing you're in
trouble one two three ah heavy one two
three
one more big scoop
one two
three stop hold tension
this big dude is 12 feet long and weighs
600 pounds that is a lot of alligator
but i know they get as big as 19 feet in
over a thousand pounds oh man
and all 75 teeth are like wolf canines
and this head feels like it could weigh
100 pounds
dealing with bears and mountain lion and
stuff there's a lot of finesse and and
fall because you don't want to hurt them
and believe it or not you can hurt a
grizzly bear but these guys they're
nearly bulletproof i mean look how tough
these guys are so
all of this really is just like almost
tickling this alligator he could care
less he's tough he's the king of this
domain he knows it
these guys haven't been around for
millions of years because they're wimps
gators have ruled these swamps for
millions of years
from north carolina to the keys and
their numbers are exploding
but they're not alone
it turns out there's another giant
reptile right here in gator country
but this one owns the salt water
and right now
is the perfect time to track him down
look at this
see i think this is the tail right here
look at this
you can see the claws
so let's walk this way
this is the home of the american
crocodile
and right now it's nesting season
okay
check this out right here
as you can see where a crocodile walked
right up here and laid on the beach in
the sun
you can see the belly scales you can see
its tail swoosh to the sand
i mean this nesting season is in full
swing right now so there literally could
be female crocs on this beach right now
i'm not sure if a crocodile is like a
grizzly bear i mean
will it defend its nest
it's a little nuts for me to be on this
beach right now
i know crocodiles are super protective
mothers
they help their young to hatch
and even carry them down to the water
just a few decades ago the endangered
american crocodile was on its way out
but now they're making a comeback in
gator country i i'm definitely going
through this feeling and
that uh you know i want to see one of
these guys
i want to see a crocodile but
do i want to see a defensive
female crocodile the first time i've
ever seen one i don't know if i'm ready
for that
i don't think they make crocodile spray
oh wait right there right there right
there's them
watch your back watch your back i want
you back
i just saw right in here something
moving across and i think it was a
female crocodile she must have been
sitting right up over here doing
something but she slipped right over
that way
stay close stay close to me
in dangerous situations i'm always
looking out for my camera team but today
i need them to watch out for my butt too
man this is so bizarre tracking a very
large predator on a beach
a lot of nesting right here
these vests are easy to miss they just
look like a giant pile of sand
so
i'm not sure if i should approach or
what but i want to see if there's a
crocodile i've got to see you
watch this nest
[Applause]
what do you think should we go in there
just stay close to me
i'm hearing something
just stay close
right there
in the water right there
going underneath that branch
pretty big one
i'm looking at my first
wild american crocodile oh look at this
right here
it's a crock egg
that's not good news though probably a
raccoon you know every little croc
counts right now so that's a bummer
but you know we've got
crocs laying eggs we got scavengers we
got tracks everywhere this is a great
spot right here
to put up some camera traps
this will be a great spot
i think that's going to stay out of the
high tide never had that problem in
montana
i mean here's an animal i've never set a
camera trap up on so all i can do is
take what i know from other predators
and try to apply it to the situation
so as i set up the camera traps and then
walk away
i don't know if i'm gonna get anything
well
the cameras made it through the nights
that's good
i don't see any fresh
tracks of any sort but that doesn't mean
anything
see what i got
oh what's that
oh cool it's a raccoon
that might be the same one that raided
the nest
after looking through all this footage
there it is
one single frame of an american
crocodile
and then just like most predators
she's gone
but the good news is the crocs are
returning to the florida shores
the only problem
it's a very different florida they're
coming back to
so here we
go of southern florida
pretty amazing
when it comes to understanding wildlife
back home in montana i like to get up on
top of a high mountain
get a good look around and see
what is going on out there in that
landscape
here in florida
good luck finding a mountain this land
is absolutely flat
the swampy everglades is more than 4 000
square miles it's almost as big as
connecticut
it's actually a really wide slow moving
river
and these days much of that river is
running dry
this is not the place alligators and
crocodiles once knew
i mean i've never seen a place with such
a actual drastic line where it is so
obvious like literally to the west
that land goes
for a long long ways about a building
and to the right
there's a building on every chunk
of land
and it is
quite a difference
i don't think i've ever looked at a
landscape that's more fragmented from
the metropolitan area of miami to you
know
these big sugar cane views
i mean as far as i can see
this is nothing but open spaces full of
some sort of crop and that all used to
be prime alligator habitat
one thing's for sure alligators need
water so when it dries up and goes away
the alligator's gonna go somewhere else
to find it even if that somewhere else
is a launch pad
kennedy space center sits in the middle
of a wildlife refuge
it's become an important sanctuary for
gators and nasa wants to make sure
they're doing well
the only way to really know how a large
predator is doing is to track them and
whether that's a bear a wolf or an
alligator that means you got to get your
hands on them
right there
so we saw an alligator it went down now
we're just trying to find it
right here
russ lauers has captured over 1600
gators for nasa
his research is monitoring the health of
this entire ecosystem
it's slippery up on this deck
so i've got something to admit i am not
a good swimmer
and the thought of an alligator pulling
me overboard
is not good
it's right here yeah
you got it
i'm gonna put the snare on him okay he's
doing a great job getting him get him up
oh don't let let's line up line out line
out
keep the tag just got wrapped
this guy
let's get him
got him good this time this guy is a
snappy dude you don't want to get your
fingers toes
anything near this guy's mouth
good job casey
all right
nice
that's good
beautiful okay
one two three
all right one more
one two three go
okay
there we go
this one all by yourself
yeah that's pretty dang cool
finally gator on the deck i did it and
it was awesome
look at this
there's an alligator high five right
there
but only three of them have these big
gnarly claws in the front it's like a
eagle or something look at those big
curved suckers
casey it's not a recapture it's a new
one new guy it's a new one
so that's awesome a big adult like this
will provide new data for the study
under the skin here
and then pull a black trigger right
correct
[Applause]
there you go cool
so just put the pit tag in that's uh
just like a microchip you put in a dog
or a cat just identify this individual
when and where
and by whom
captured right here
casey i just checked it sex yeah the
largest female we've had to study
largest female
yeah well that's pretty dang cool i
might not be good at uh capturing gators
but i'm always good at capturing the
ladies
well you caught a big lady big mama
all right big mama go have some babies
okay let's slide her back real easy
okay sweetheart
ready got it okay
see you later little lady
man she's fighting she's a good animal
feisty
biggest lady we've ever caught
that's sweet that's neat that's some
good data
but we're just getting started
all right
gator one gator two we have a gator on
there all right
one reason these nasa gators are so cool
is because we're right here by the ocean
and these gators are hunting in fresh
water and salt water
and that's not normal for gators
i've seen this kind of intelligence in
wolves who traditionally hunt on land
but have learned to fish
he's going into the death roll
and shows just how adaptable these
gators are
these guys have been around longer than
any predator that i've had my hands on
and you know i've tracked
my lions grizzly bears packs of wolves
this is like the perfect american
predator right here
but even the perfect predator can't go
it alone
if i really want to understand gator
country i need to go upstream
100 miles away
up here there's a critter who's got the
gators back a big furry predator that i
know well
here's tracks
oh yeah
go check those out
very typical black bear front paw track
here five toes this guy's definitely got
those big spread out like i call him
fred flintstone toes
likely a male a younger bear 200 pound
range
headed that way and like bears often do
taking the path of least resistance and
why not use this nice road
joe guthrie studies black bears and how
they use the forest this is well
traveled right here
it's actually private land but the
owners have banded together to save it
from development
look here
yeah this is great you know you can see
there's a lot of bear activity these
black bears love to get into these
rotten trees you can see where black
bears come in here tore this rotten wood
up looking for
termites and ants down here in this
harder less rotted wood you can see the
just one claw mark kind of giving that
black bear away
the bears don't know it but their
protected habitat is actually the
headwaters of the everglades
and when it rains here it filters
downstream to resupply gator
country alligators
alligators and black bears
stomping around the same place man so
it's uh how they deal with that oh yeah
there's a gator right there
in in montana a bear sees water it runs
in without second spot you know it's
like water yay
here
i mean nothing here can walk up to the
water without second thought or it
doesn't live very long
it's got a lot of fresh tracks
we're moving into an area there's been a
lot of black fair activity
a lot of rubs a lot of things so
right now it's that prime time for bears
so we're just gonna sneak in there
hopefully get a glimpse
go step on the blind coats camera boy
wait wait wait
do you see it
he's right there
right there
a florida black bear
looks like a young bear just hanging out
definitely sees us curious doesn't know
what i do
now these bears don't survive by being
dumb
so i don't think that bear is going to
give
give us a whole lot of more time
years forward definitely it's locked in
but hasn't really identified what we are
yet because i'm laying here like an
alligator in the sand
there she goes
but while i'm watching this bear
[Music]
joe gets word that another bear has
walked into one of his traps
oh that doesn't sound good
all right
okay everybody
everybody
siri what do you do when the buggy
steering brakes and you have a bear and
a trap
trying to guess what you want me to do
well you could try to fix the steering
column on this thing so we can get there
[Music]
there's no choice but to hook it
they're going to mix up tranquilizer
that
will correspond with the weight of the
animal
nice shot
bears out that's good
and a beautiful
bear besides that and there's almost no
tooth wear here at all definitely not
wore down at all this hair coat is
amazing i mean around here
i've been sweating
all
the time i can't believe these black
bears can walk around with this black
coat and this florida sunshine and have
this humidity and still have a hair coat
that's so
thick and beautiful
a three-year-old female black bear in
spring would never look this healthy in
montana or anywhere else this area is
part of florida the headwaters the
everglades these black bears are
thriving it's perfect it's paradise for
them here
check this out right here
it's really cool just to look at a black
bear's paw here these claws are designed
for many things but one thing they can
do really well is climb trees
they're short they're curved
and they can just dig them into the bark
and shimmy up something without branches
even a telephone pole no matter how big
they are
but if you look at the toes right here
curved toes five toes in the front
enough there's a grizzly bear
that that pit toe would sit right about
there
more more of a straight line in the toes
black bear kind of curves around if you
see a track it's a sure way to tell
this gps collar will reveal how this
bear moves in and around this forest
and for the first time we're attaching a
national geographic critter cam to a
florida black bear
we may get the first ever footage of a
bear interacting with a gator this is
one thing i've never done
to put a camera on a bear to see how it
walks across the land and see what kind
of choices it's making
okay i think we're good guys
see you later i came to florida with a
lot of unknowns and i wanted to discover
and get to know the croc and the gator
and i bumped into a black bear
i mean they are intertwined
with a croc in the gator and it's
important
that they remain healthy if they
can have everything that they need to
remain healthy
that'll trickle down and the everglades
will remain healthy
[Music]
this is the first ever critter cam
footage of a florida black bear
and it's really cool to see how she's
falling her nose moving around
but right to a gator palm you better
watch out
wait a minute
that's not a gator
it's another bear
i bet they're siblings
this is so cool to see
these bears are healthy and doing great
that means they can roam all over
and out here
bears aren't welcome
florida's already got its hands full
with gators
here he goes
if i go out my back door in montana i
expect to see bears and wolves and deer
but if i went out my back door and i saw
a giant reptile in my swimming pool
that might freak me out
yeah this is like right in the middle of
a presidential area yeah we have
alligators turning up just about
anywhere nowadays you know i've gone to
a few like wildlife human conflict
things but not in the middle of a
neighborhood like this well this may be
nothing at all i mean
but we'll be prepared just in case
there's over 15 000 alligator complaints
a year in florida the biggest issue is
there's just not enough room for all
these alligators all these crocodiles
and all of the humans
i don't see oh there's something at the
bottom oh yeah right in the corner
all right we got something in there
yep it's an american crocodile wow that
is yeah
this is a little bit more rare to find
in a pool than we would an alligator
so here you go okay
okay
catching a croc at a pool is new to me
i'm definitely a fish out of water and
that's exactly where i want to stay
oh great
let's just be safe and uh we'll have us
a crocodile
got him deeper that wasn't the plan
there well be aware that if the snare
does not detach from the pole he could
pull you in
that would be really bad
anytime i have a new wildlife encounter
my adrenaline goes through the roof i'm
hot i'm sweating i'm nervous i'm not
even shaking a little bit
be careful pull straight up fast and
hard
[Applause]
be careful
[Applause]
gnarly teeth
wow
[Applause]
yeah
all right
okay hold steady i got a channel now
ready for me
wow
so the fact that this is a american
crocodile what is
this guy's future his future is bright
you and i are going to go release this
animal immediately and hopefully he'll
stay out of swimming pools ready uh kind
of yeah
we're good
this guy's stout
wow heavy we're whipping my butt you
must be strong
in my lifetime i went from
not being able to find one for 20 years
now i'm seeing crocodiles all over town
which that's a great thing for the
species but the issue now is the humans
are not accepting of the crocodile's
presence
it's the same story with america's
wolves
both species have come back from near
extinction but now some people just
aren't comfortable with having them
around
all right let's take this gal to a good
spot
if we would have found an alligator in
the pool today it would have been
euthanized but we didn't we found an
american crocodile
and they they get a lot of help in fact
they have a three strike rule
all right
this is the animal's first capture if we
capture him two more times in an urban
situation he'll be placed in captivity
but for right now he has a chance to be
a wild crocodile still so we like so
here we go
[Music]
all right go ahead and pull the knob
release the cable and work it over the
snout okay
pull all right there you go stay out of
swimming pools
it's giving you a little smile there
pretty cool american crocodile going
back out into the wild
but this croc doesn't know his home has
an intruder
and it eats crocs and gators for lunch
pythons can grow up to 25 feet
and eat almost anything
even alligators
so you're the python hunter yeah that's
what they call me the fight the hunter
i'm hitching a ride with ruben ramirez
this guy won the annual python challenge
what kind of what kind of numbers are we
talking about i would say that there's
in the tens of thousands
in wow in the florida everglades that
they have no natural predators here
reuben just starts referring to them
like they're everywhere and i'm like
really we could just pull over right
here
all right let's do it we're on
look at this place
it's like a jungle out here
yeah see look this is a good spot right
here
so if we see uh python what's the
game plan
the gate plan is make let you catch it
man
are you thinking like a snake right now
yeah i'm thinking like a snake
i'm trying to tap into my other inner
snake
yeah
man if there's one laying in here you
wouldn't have a clue nope
they are stepping on it next thing you
know it's got you
all right i have a feeling we're gonna
pull something out of here
if you see it stretched out just grab
the tail you hold it call me
okay
just grab it i'll call you
wait a minute i don't have your number
scream cool okay create the code all
right
code word python python python you got
it
come on baby
thinking like a snake thinking like a
snake
i can feel it i feel one coming out
somewhere any minute now
and it's perfect the sun's going down
it's like
when they start uh
this is a fight there's a pipeline right
here man
reuben
fights on fire you got one
i got what you're going to
get look at this dude
back to my hook here get back to my hook
look at this guy this is the biggest
snake i've ever had my hand on
and i'm going to use my
my tool here best i can
[Laughter]
you see how feisty that thing was
look at this an everglades python right
here look at this thing
this thing was strong i tell you man he
was walking up
she was right here i could barely see
her i walked past her yeah they get
camouflaged and then when i walked up i
couldn't figure out which end was
the head which it was the tail
finally i could see where it tapered
down there and i remember what you told
me
grab the tail and just hang it yeah
that's what you got to do look at this
python she's heavy
she's fat which is not a good thing
because that means
she's eating a lot she's out here
pretty much
destroying this ecosystem
you know these gals these snakes
they think it's on the female yeah by
the way it looks too it looks like she's
full of eggs too i mean it's the kind of
snake that we want to catch you know
just catching this one snake right now
you could be potentially in just this
year
taking out 50 pythons
she's full of eggs we're going to have
51 more and then all those offspring can
lay eggs and she has got plenty of years
left in her oh yeah she
could just keep that cycle going over
and over and over so every python counts
catching these every single part that's
why the florida python hunters are doing
what they can man
there it is
it's a nice snake beautiful snake
okay she measures nine feet one inch
yeah all you gotta do is just bag her up
and get her to the university as soon as
possible
there's a perfect place for python
somewhere out there in the world
it's just not here in the everglades
dude
i'm out of here good luck with the
gators man take it easy all right buddy
take it easy
so i asked ruben to drop me off just
where i like it in the middle of nowhere
because something's been bugging me
almost everything i've done in gator
country has been with some sort of help
i've captured wild gators wrinkled pool
crocs guys stuff black bears snack
pythons
i still really haven't got it alone
so i have one last mission to get closer
than ever to gators but this time i'm
going solo
right now is alligator mating season
when aggression and testosterone are at
their highest
it's an amazing event few people ever
see
and the perfect time to execute my plan
if i could find the right body of water
there are some massive alligator
congregations there's no better time
just to get out there and just to put
myself right in the middle of it and
just become
one of the gators
it's a good camping spot see the gators
are starting to show up out there
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a lot of activity going on out
there in the water
i can hear
a lot of splashing
[Music]
i'm gonna
grab the guys and uh we're gonna head
out and see what's going on
ready to do this
just gotta find that right squad
let's go down this way a bit
i just keep hearing
all this splashing out here i know it's
out here
a lot of activity
[Applause]
the only way i'm gonna take this to the
next level and really understand these
alligators is to get into their domain
tonight
it's time to head into the gator pond
but the only thing i could haul out into
the back country was a flimsy
inflatable kayak
[Music]
look at that big guy
i'm up here on solid ground
where i feel really comfortable
and he's out there
in the water
where he feels very comfortable
but tonight
i'm going
on that side
with predators size matters
and i'm counting on being the biggest
thing out there
but if a gator comes in for a bite
i'm in serious trouble
i mean look at this guy
hey dude
coming out there with you
[Applause]
i mean i'm sitting here trying to do my
job and pump up this kayak
but i have to have my head on the swivel
because i have gators
everywhere look at this
that's a big gator
he's close casey
yeah he's close i mean if he wanted to
come quick
i think i'm gonna let him eat the kayak
i mean but instantaneously that hiss
and he's coming
like literally coming
i mean what's he wanting to do here
[Music]
mr gator
[Music]
this big male alligator that's got lots
of scars on him
he's coming
to me and i don't like it
here he comes
[Music]
and i might have to get those paddles
in the morning
yeah he's
he's got that big huh
[Music]
you gonna go back out there man
i prefer it
he's not wanting to
back off
i've got
this guy
i've got a bunch of guys over here
looking at me
oh we got our gator coming in
you got your paddle
ready i'm ready
if i'm going to enter the water
it's now
or never
i mean i've got gears
all around me they're everywhere
this guy's coming over with purpose
[Music]
look at that
hey man
you got to be careful
and then usually when these big gators
do that
because they're being territorial during
the mating season and chasing off their
males kind of showing their dominance
look at this big guy right here
very close to my boat
i have to admit
it kind of freaked me out a little bit
but i just felt something wiggling
around underneath my boat
right now my butt
is like a ham
sitting
right
down in the water
i don't know if i like that
this behavior is bizarre i mean i
thought they'd be more shy but it shows
that these alligators are super
intelligent predators
they're curious they hear something they
want to come over and check it out
look right here is another big one
i'm out here because i crave moments
like this
when i'm in the wild with one of
america's great predators
just getting down to alligator level out
here
in their kingdom
just so cool
i didn't see any mating but the gators
gave me something better
an incredible moment without fear
just shared curiosity
crocodile and alligator a lot like
brazil
people don't understand them they fear
them
and this wilderness is going to exist
then the people who
live with these predators need to
understand what they are
they didn't take that fear
and change into respect
that's amazing
[Music]
[Music]
you